hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game it's from the 1965
candidates tournament or rather
candidates matches as it was uh played
in that cycle it's mikael towel versus
ben larson and uh tal already defeated
elias portis in the quarter finals of
this uh event and ben larson uh defeated
uh borislav ivkov and now they have to
face each other so it was a really
really intense match this is the tenth
game of the match already uh and it
started by larson winning then tal drew
then tal won then two games were drawn
then larson wins again takes the lead
tal uh retaliates uh you know equalizes
then three draws and now this is game
10. so the the the most uh incredible
one in the match it would seem so let's
check it out and see why everyone enjoys
this game uh so much so atal has the
white pieces and he opens with e4
we have c5 by larson knight to f3 and
the knight to c6 going for the sicilian
defense we have d4 capture sunday for
knight captures on d4 and now e6 uh and
here just knight to c3 nicely continuing
the timon of variation uh we have d6 and
now bishop to e3
we have knight to f6 and now we have f4
so by playing knight to f6 black
transposes into the scavenging variation
of the sicilian and f4 is the start of
the
matanovic attack against this setup with
bishop to e7 queen to f3 now preparing
to castle queen side and the both
players castle so castles castles this
was very often back in the days and also
uh it's it's popular today you can even
play this today so queen to c7 and now
knight d to b5 attacking the sorry
knights d to b5 attacking the queen on
c7 queen back to b8 and now tal starts
attacking on the king side with g4 but
this is nothing unexpected uh larson
just kicks away the knight from b5
knights to d4 and he trades off a pair
of knights here knight captures on d4
bishop captures and now b5 preparing b4
and he wants to put his bishop on b7 is
going to be very useful here and start
an attack of his own so here g5
attacking the knight knights to d7 and
now even bishop to d3 thou says he
doesn't care about this pawn to be for
move uh and he even invites larson to
play it yeah solaris and of course goes
before it is the strongest move there is
no argument here and thal doesn't play
knights to a four or even knight to b1
or even knight to e2 tao of course plays
knight to d5 and he says uh that's a
free piece you can take it but then if
you if you take it my bishop fare
becomes fully operational but this is
one of those cases where it's impossible
to decline uh this uh sacrifice so let's
say you don't capture the knight
uh the bishop on e7 is hanging let's say
you just go back bishop to d8 well then
tal would play knight to f6 check and
again if your capture is just going to
be really really bad then the the rooks
can come to g1 the the bishop is still a
very very strong queen can come to h5
you will not be able to fend off this
attack so let's say you uh
decline even this uh knight captures an
h7 and now you can't really decline this
you have to you know capture it and now
after capture let's say queen h5 check
king g8 now even bishop captures and g7
can be played king captures check and
then after finally the king moves g6 and
that's it uh once you play something
like knight f6 you prevent checkmate
we're going to play rook h to g1 and now
there's nothing to play if queen a7
preventing you know any tricks on the
seventh rank we're just gonna play g7
and now either queen the h8 is checkmate
or if you play knight here to defend
this then just captures here is
checkmate you can even bring um you know
a rook into the game because there's a
you know a rook here and it doesn't
really matter what you what you take
into the game uh so instead after this
knight to d5 uh larson accepts the
knight we have e captures on the e5 and
it is in fact the strong
strongest move recommended by the engine
and now e captures on d5 and now what
tal did here is that he gave up a piece
but um
he really disco coordinated black's
pieces they can't really communicate
well and he sort of has this invisible
barrier along the e file as you can see
all of these squares are controlled by
toss pieces and most importantly the
pawns are controlling e5 and e6 so
that's going to be very very important
and how is black to get uh
back into the game so the
sacrifice isn't fully correct and you
have to play g6 here in order to
withstand uh the full pressure of tal's
attack but this is something that we
know today you know with the help of
modern engines uh in the game f5 was
played and this uh well this uh makes it
a little bit easier for tal to continue
the attack he plays rook d to e1
puts pressure on the bishop on e7 and
now how do you defend do you move the
bishop back or do you play rook to f7 to
defend this bishop so you you could
consider both and both moves have their
merits but bishop to d8 is much much
better here but here
it's um almost as if tal already got
under larsen's skin and here he was
maybe thinking okay i'm not going to
have all of my pieces on the back rank
i'm playing against style this is uh you
know i might as well resign right away
so he played rook to f7 instead and now
tal continues with h4 uh we have bishop
to b7 and this is the
uh magical moment in the game where
where nothing really happens but it
could have happened uh here i think
white of course could continue this in
many ways you could play h5 you could
play
the immediate the g6 which i think is in
the spirit of the position uh but the
thing is uh this is the the candidates
and tal really wants to do well he has
the attack if he wins this uh then he
gets uh goes into the finals and then
maybe maybe he will be able to challenge
uh the world champion again as you know
uh tal already was the world champion
then he lost his world championship
title and of course he's still in the
game he wants the he wants to challenge
the the champion again uh and here i
will just show a fun line that uh you
know if this was any other game other
than the candidate style would have uh
gone for it that starts with the g6 so
you could play h5 and g6 but you know
often in chess if you want to make the
attack happen just a little bit faster
then you play you reverse the move order
so you don't prepare
g6 by pushing h5 uh you push g6 right
away because it comes with tempo and
only after this is captured we play h5
and now we're opening up the h file and
that will be sufficient for us to win
the attack if black insists on keeping
the h file closed we don't care we just
continue h6 and now if g6 even h7 check
and that's it uh for example rook
captures we're going to play rook
captures and that's it just queen h3
check king g8 we're gonna deliver a
check here king of seven queen g7 check
here and you can even capture here with
checkmate so many many things are
possible here uh of course there's a
a lot more to consider and you know
things could go wrong if you missed
something so tal first place bishop
captures on f5
rook captures on f5 and now rook
captures on e7 attacking the knight here
but now knights to e5 so this is why
the whole idea maybe of uh
capturing on f5 isn't all that
impressive because you allow the knight
into the game but only somewhat because
now queen to e4
attacks the rook the knight is still
hanging so queen the f8 defends the rook
and attacks the white rook and now f
captures an e5 and now uh of course uh
tal wonder uh p is back but you don't
have to worry about rook to f1 if if
something like this queen captures king
to d2 and white is completely safe here
there is no good way for black to
continue this attack or anything so here
we have rook f4 by larson queen e3 rook
f3 are continuing to harass the the
white queen queen to e2 but now you
can't play rook f2 because the bishop
guards that and now only now larson
trades we have queen captures on a7
queen captures on f3 and d captures an
e5 so now the material has equalized a
little bit but tal uh is still up upon
so here we have rook to e1 preparing to
grab this pawn as well
rook to d8 and now rook captures an e5
and now queen to d6 it seems that larson
is not winning the d5 pawn
but not so fast tarl plays queen to f4
and now the d5 pawn cannot be captured
if you play bishop captures on d5 uh
rookie check wins the game uh you can't
block this uh you can to move the king
uh you have to capture this and then
just queen captures and d6 wins the
queen and the game so after queen to f6
we have rook to f8 attacking tal's queen
queen to e for now
uh keeping an eye on that uh e4 pawn and
now uh you can't really
do any threats with black if rook to f1
we already said that the king is
perfectly safe on d2 so larson figures
uh let's play b3 let's free up the b4
square for the for the black queen then
maybe we can do some damage so tal
accepts this a captures on b3 we have
rook to f1 with king d2 and now queen to
be for with check but i'll just uh
blocks to check with c3 and now of
course you can't capture here because
rookie 8 and that's a game over so queen
back to b6 and now now we said that if
rook to e8 checked then black can block
with rook to f8 that's black's uh main
plan uh but stall finds an incredible
move that you know uh
completely uh eliminates all uh chances
of black surviving this and that is
bishop to c5 really an incredible move
uh attacking the queen and now if the
queen moves we have the f8 square
covered if the queen moves rook e8 it
just wins the game on the spot so the
bishop has to be captured but now comes
rook to e8 check the idea of the
sacrifice was to remove the black queen
from the control of the e6 square so
rook to f8 blocking now comes queen to
e6 check the idea why bishop was
sacrificed on c5 king the h8 only move
and now feel free to pause the video and
win this game in the quickest way
possible for tal while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations i know you guys
spotted this move you know the the the
instant i uh you know you saw the
previous move but just in case for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is of course queen to f7 this is what
tao played and he was in this position
on move 37 that ben larson resigned in
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here so with this game uh he loses
the match and it is tal who wins the the
the semi-final match uh and he goes uh
into the finals of the candidates
matches uh and there he will face boris
vasilevich spassky but that's uh a story
for a different saga so we're going to
discuss that at some point i just wanted
to show you this game as you guys said
that you are you know enjoying the
sudden uh you know burst of tall games
so i hear you resign because there's no
defense you're going to win the rook and
that's it of course if the rook is
captured this is just checkmate you have
to give up the queen that's it and other
than this you really don't have anything
to to even try here
uh so yeah now that's the game hope you
guys uh enjoyed it uh i would like to
wish a very happy birthday to
christopher i hope you had a great day
and you know spend it with so many uh
many friends and that you enjoyed some
chess while you were at it and i would
like to thank tom darrell jeremy
zwidkovic michael kennedy and dylan
stannett for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it uh as usual you can check
to all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of everything
that's happening in the chess world uh
and you know just checking up on your
wonderful suggestions uh so thank you i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and yeah if you're
wondering yes this is the same bent
larson that faced bobby fischer in the
candidates matches in 1971 uh but uh you
know
lost uh lost uh zero to six the bobby
fischer that's that's the same guy yes
uh see you soon guys